[Music]  [Music]  the tweed sport jacket is the nucleus of  your fall wardrobe whether it be a  herringbone or a gun check or blanket  plaid  it's the middle of winter but maybe it's  not top coat weather yet even though  it's a sport jacket you can do a  slipknot scarf with it and wear it out  into the freezing cold  look at the tweet jacket is kind of your  fall denim jacket something that you're  just gonna wear the heck out of it looks  great done in a very casual way it can  be very elegant it can be very dressed  down you should actually buy a couple of  them because I know you're gonna get a  lot of versatility out of wearing it at  the office and also on the weekend  it's the perfect sport jacket for fall  [Music]